let me look in the gruesome sometimes
disturbing anime and manga series attack
on Titan is pretty popular but there
have only been a handful of video game
adaptations to varying degrees of
success
Kauai tech most take is structurally
nothing more than the attack on Titan
property grafted on to the dynasty
Warriors framework and painfully lacks
any sort of gameplay variety but its use
of the series elements makes it a unique
and sometimes exhilarating experience
attack on titan recounts the events of
the anime and then some telling tales
past the show's first season and
encroaching on the upcoming second each
chapter is broken up into a handful of
missions that set you on a map with
specific objectives these range from
simply hacking Titans to bits
protecting a specific structure on the
map or escorting soldiers from point A
to point B this is as complicated as
things get the latter half of the game
is unfortunately padded out and to add
length to the campaign you are forced to
complete dozens of small formally
optional side missions before you can
advance the story
these are monotonous and a total chore
you spend most of the game slinging
through towns and forest using
omnidirectional mobility gear special
machinery used to move through the air
and scale Heights quickly attacking
Titans requires you to lock onto one of
the Giants limbs and use your odium gear
to gain speed as you fly towards it the
faster you're moving the greater the
damage will do and hopefully slice off
its meaty leg or arm in one stroke you
can kill the monster for good by aiming
for the nape of its neck it takes some
getting used to and there are some
nuance and learning when to deploy your
anchors and when to use gas canisters to
propel yourself forward or up
there is a severe lack of variety in
mission structure and if you played a
mousou game the drill will be familiar
once you've completed all of the maps
required objectives one final boss Titan
will appear for you to take down these
boss Titans don't feel any different
from the smaller monstrosity as you
encounter and it's an easy kill even the
different types of Titans big small
beastly armored can all be taken down in
the same way with very little strategy
in fact even on harder difficulty levels
attack on Titan presents rather simple
challenges making for some unappealing
gameplay through the latter half of the
campaign the mission layout is the same
for the multiplayer expedition mode
where you can team up with three other
players to take on optional challenge
missions but there is no incentive to
team up and take down a Titan you can
simply zip to opposite sides of the map
and route the enemy more quickly alone
little fanfare or reward should you
decide to work cooperatively no lattice
Nara story demo ahsoka no Kyojin dome
okay trestle an attachable a rotten eye
Bukhari qey cutscenes aren't as dramatic
as the show but the visuals themselves
are impressively good like cells taken
straight from the anime this includes
the absolutely horrifying and sometimes
painful to look at Titans their sexless
bodies are entirely naked more than once
I found myself hurtling towards the
ground with a giant butt directly in
front of my face or trapped beneath the
quivering belly of a downed Titan most
of the time the framerate held up but
when the screen started to fill up with
those titans things became muddy the
action slowed down and the lag prevented
me from landing hits attack on Titan
also includes an oversimplified
equipment upgrade and modification
system that makes your blades slightly
more powerful or grants you longer
aerial time after a certain point you
can also choose which character you play
as which is fun but what matters the
most in attack on Titan is its excellent
traversal system in which you use the
odium gear to fly through the air whip
across skylines and swing around trees
and Titans like some kind of
anti-gravity Tarzan
it feels so good to sling between
buildings nailing Titans in the nape of
their neck for the one-shot kill as you
fly from objective to objective I felt
powerful and free like I was actually
living in the attack on Titan universe
the odium gear is such a hallmark of the
show and having it done justice in the
form of a gameplay mechanic was
thrilling this game lets you get up
close and personal with those terrifying
Titans that make this series so great
and that is enough to make the game
worth your time attack on Titan may have
some technical issues and is
systematically simple but it does
justice to the attack on Titan property
well-tried Musa layout aside is an
excellent job that you feel like you're
part of the fryin humanity's war
battling Titans and swinging through the
skies with feature astok military gear
you